four five next Shield
uh this is such a cool sequence yes oh
oh man he did a slide slid into home he
didn't see
ah
he should have a little instrument
[Music]
oh no how is a frog living in a hot
spring because those frogs are going to
be in literally a Boiling Pot of water
welcome back to new rock stars the
Mandalorian chapter 24 the season three
finale wraps up quite a bit of din jarin
in the newly adopted din grogu but
leaving a few unanswered questions from
this season but I think leaving us
wondering if there's any story left to
tell for these characters or if these
two might just pop up uh in other kinds
of shows or you know a little arc on
Ahsoka a little arc on the book of Boba
Fett season six we don't know yet but I
think meanwhile anyone convinced that ax
woes or the armor were the spies are now
watching this episode shouting
this is the break represents Wookie
Lakes it's our weekly Mandalorian after
show I'm Eric Boss Hector Navarro isn't
feeling too well this week we'll miss
him hope he feels better soon my Easter
egg breakdown this episode is going to
come out tomorrow but right now I'm here
discussing this finale episode with
Tommy Bechtel
another Mandalorian season as closed
captioning not available
wants to do what like six seasons of
this show I I don't know if that's
official I'm not quite sure how you get
three more out but you know what
I've been wrong about a lot of things in
my life so a lot of people said I could
I couldn't eat 10 hot dogs in one
sitting I proved them wrong every
Saturday so you know if anybody's
wondering why my background looks
different right now it's because I'm in
I'm on technically I'm on vacation but I
am working today I know reacting to this
finale but uh yeah I'll be back in the
blue dungeon before too long so if I
look at sound different that's why but
it's still the same meaning it's a
Multiverse to me
thank you you look and sound great too
Tommy and it's partially because I think
both of us are wearing these exclusive
shirts that you get at nerd right dot
shop it's the best way to support new
rock stars we're both wearing our
Mandalorian inspired designs I got a
grogu now dingradu design shirt uh
they're really comfortable it's really
the best way to support us uh nerdright
dot shop and thank to everyone who's
bought our Mandalorian shirts over the
course of this season and those of you
who have written shout outs we love all
you guys and we really appreciate your
support shout out to the shout outers
alright so what the fat happened in this
episode Eric first of all let's talk
about this episode was called the return
but the return of what so many ways to
interpret what a return means we return
things to stores things returned to us
that we lost uh Jedi's return
Sith Revenge all right now we start guns
blazing is Bo Katan and co-fleam off
Gideon and his Troopers meanwhile ax is
rocketeering through mandalore's stormy
atmosphere to get some reinforcements
Eric I don't know did you have like a
weird feeling ax was just gonna like
emerge into space and get blown to like
a thousand bits or something I really
yeah I thought someone was whoever the
other spy was turned out it was no one
yeah but whoever else was just gonna
pick him out of the sky and he was just
gonna come crash into Earth but no thank
God that was not the case 100 and
especially after he's like his
Transmissions breaking up kind of
confirming the like yes the storm is
what makes it so nothing can come in
around or or I think it was the storm
with the mixture of some moth Gideon
signal Jam yeah I think it could have
been a bit of both yeah well I think
you're probably right about that din is
still in rough shape he's being escorted
to his cell he attempts at daring escape
and then is aided by ig-12 and grogu and
din says listen we've got to once and
for all kill moth Gideon and end this
I'm not doing another season season
of Giancarlo Esposito coming in for the
last two episodes of the season and
making everybody miserable because he's
such a tremendous Force I don't want it
to be about him anymore I want it to be
about me and you grogu and the only way
we do it is we kill this guy and grogu's
like yes yes yes yes yes
but some of the Mandos they head to
Safety in an underground Garden where I
always explained that life can survive
on the surface of Mandela or something
they previously thought impossible I
think even well Mandalore was still a
functioning planet right like they're
they thought things were going to grow
on the surface in those domes they said
it was uh thought to be you know extinct
or for centuries yeah before the Civil
War it's an interesting history we'll
get into in the breakdown but yeah I
think it's interesting they have this
little Greenhouse there they literally
had a Jurassic world life finds a way
reference it sounds like they're like
life no persist light persists that's
what we'll say here but yes it was nice
to see and it gives a Mandalore you know
last week I was like this place is a
why are they trying to reclaim
it now we see why it's got a nice
backyard patio Garden yes and I say give
us a nerd riot.shop merch shirt with
Sasha Banks pointing to a blade of
Mandalorian grass and going life figures
it the F out uh I think that let's sell
that immediately I love that they I love
when they give our girl Sasha a a line
or two in the episodes she looks so good
as a Mandalorian like I just I don't
know I'm a fan anyway uh Gideon then
launches his tie bombers uh to attack
the Mandalorian Fleet moth Gideon
discovers Dean has escaped and for the
second time in two weeks Eric he tells
us he's gonna take care of this himself
come on Mom open up your heart let
people help you you've created these
amazingly armored Mandalorian Trooper or
Mando inspired Troopers with
flamethrowers they can't help themselves
but use it every every turn speaking of
help din contacts our favorite r5d4 and
asks him to get the schematics tomorrow
Command Center and R5 does it because
he's a total badass so we'll never say
no to a mission but not without a little
interference from Mouse droids and I
hate Mouse droids Eric I hate them so
much and let me tell you one of my
favorite things that has ever happened
in a Star Wars thing when our 5d4
propels himself back out of muff
Gideon's base one of the droids about
stories gets blown off the side of a
cliff from the propulsion I'm sure
you'll point that out it made me so
happy because those Mouse droids all
they do is Snitch they snitch the
snitches wind up in deep ditches bro
well they snitched just to each other
yeah like they I thought they were gonna
bring someone else to come like
investigate this but he just told the
other Mouse droids and they all just
swarmed and made more Sirens that's it
that's all they did I mean I think the
next step of recourse is to alert like
all hundred of them yes and then they
all just nuds
droids I like that they have Little
Sirens too they just suck you know what
someone should step on them ax finally
makes it to the Mando destroyer and
sends all the other ships and soldiers
down to help I'm waiting for the big
betrayal it doesn't happen Bowen didn't
need to help desperately ax he says get
them down there there's a great sequence
of them all kind of flying down sliding
off the back ends of the like so it kind
of reminded me of actual War like Army
Rangers that like jump out of the cargo
plates yeah I love that I I mean
everything with the with the skydiving
mandalorians like I I kind of want to
know who the rest of them were like I
guess all of them were just kind of
hanging out up there ready to strike
like I'm I'm glad they got mobilized
rather than just being victims this
episode of the of the Thai Interceptor
Fleet it was awesome I loved all the the
aerial battle combat in this episode in
this hallway sequence of Mando fighting
his way down these Shield games oh my
gosh one by one didn't feel like Nick's
player release yes
like it was so great it was like classic
Mando action incredible I had great
Cadence had a great everything din is
knifing shooting knifing shoot it's like
like using all of the physical acting I
have to assume shout out to Brandon
Wayne and uh was it Keith Crowder to
imagine they did a lot of that work and
they they knocked it out of the park uh
and that after that didn't Grogan
discovered that Gideon is cloning
himself what a narcissist and den says
clones no we're gonna kill them all
we're gonna kill them all but I'm gonna
push 10 buttons and all the Clones are
gone uh yeah I like how One of the
settings is just like if you hit the
right combination of buttons the tanks
burst yes and fill out a bunch of uh
sopping floppy Chicago Esposito corpses
all over all over there some of them
probably looked like Gus Fringe after
visiting uh tukastaka Mecca or whatever
do you think at least one of them might
have lived it's just kind of walking
around like well Eric you know one of my
one of my crazy theories is that MAF
Gideon is so evil it was the moth Gideon
that died at the end uh clone moth
Gideon like oh yeah at that point who's
the real one there's no way of knowing
we'll never know it's gonna be like a
soap opera somehow MAF Gideon returned
so the Mando Cavalry arrives gonna get
as you said Eric an absolutely sick
battle in the sky scene soldiers
colliding in the sky jet pack on Jetpack
the armorer hammering people out of the
sky that wants confirming to us she's
actually on the side of good both Eric
and I were pretty sure the armor was
going to be uh revealed to be evil and
unfortunately as always happens our
hearts are broken and now we have to
mute our replies on Twitter for at least
two weeks speak for yourself I won it I
want all right
send it all to Mt this time leave us
alone no he doesn't deserve it but you
know just spread the wealth a little bit
okay so Danny grogu confront Gideon who
tells him he was making clones of
himself that could use the force and you
guys ruined it if I tried a little bit
harder to to hide into uh barricade this
and I thought he was going to be
standing in front of those things and
blocking them himself where was he he's
like I'll lure him into a random other
hanger where we'll fight why not fight
in front of your other clones and
protect them if they're so valuable to
you yeah I thought I'll be honest I you
know I love this show I thought the
entire last like five to ten minutes of
the MAF Gideon Saga was a little bit
right like a little kind of like why is
this so easy why is everything so hard
and then all of a sudden it's like
explode clone cages and then walk into
Ahmad Gideon's Lair and he's just kind
of like I'll shut the door that part the
fight wasn't easy I think just getting
to that fight was uh you know well I
guess the the bridge sequence where he's
fighting through the the shields was so
very difficult so I retract my statement
partially anyway yeah
yeah summons his praetorian guards and
things are looking pretty bleak for Our
Heroes they get separated moth is
fighting din Griffin's fighting the
guards Bo Katan comes in to save the day
she and Gideon are fighting gin rescues
grogu grogu's rescued din by turning him
into a more human father they've saved
each other and it's not looking good uh
for Bo getting cracks of dark saber with
his head he's like that suit is so
strong he's like sorry dark Savers
destroyed what an incredible moment that
felt so understated now I understand
like the dark saber in general I think
is just kind of getting deep
mythologized this season but the fact
that like no character we get to see
their eyes as this Legacy weapon over
countless Generations that's destroyed
yeah like it just felt like we moved on
past it so quick and we just had a
character say the dark Sabers know more
but it was like something that jaycarlo
Esposito said in a booth over ADR it
felt like it had no meaning in that
moment I I completely agree that the
dark saber should be destroyed
narratively so the mandalorians can move
on past it yeah but just like give that
moment some dramatic weight you know it
just felt like it happened in the midst
of battle where it was like the eighth
most exciting thing to happen in that
battle right absolutely and as you said
it was kind of an 80 hour afterthought
the darksaber is destroyed let's move on
speaking of moving on axwells is about
to crash a star destroyer into the base
so everybody needs to move on out of
there which most of them do except for
Dean Bo and grogu who missed the message
and uh were about to be well baked as
MAF Gideon who dies and I've in the Epic
pose that all villains must die in the
Christ foes as the Flames engulf him and
grogu goes nope Force bubble and I don't
know how physics works so I guess there
was some sort of vacuum that took all
those Flames away because eventually the
force bubble lasts long enough for all
the Flames to completely retrieve or
maybe this Star Destroyer just kept
burrowing into the core of of Mandalore
and like eventually the Flames all went
down with it I don't know yeah it seems
like people have been able to use the
force to resist the vacuum of space in
Star Wars so presumably they can
redirect airflow to prevent fire from
consuming all the oxygen surrounding
them I'm not going to question it too
much I didn't question it I just said oh
good little little guy saved him now
speaking of little guys Ragnar is
finally given his ceremony and you know
that the mandalorians have learned their
lesson because they're doing it in a
body of water where a giant murderous
creature is mere feet away so uh you
know they've really grown from the first
episode everyone has learned a great
lesson uh as long as you do it in a cave
no one can hear you scream uh so they
did it on the top steps of the pool kind
of the shallow end before that steep
drop off so it's true so you know
Amanda's like don't go on the step
number six after that it's just like
step number six is a doozy so Ragnar
gets a ceremony and then says can my boy
also get baptized and the armor is like
no because he can't talk you idiot and
he's like well he's not my foundling
anymore now he's my son well I'll call
him Apprentice but we know like in
Princess Bride where As You Wish means I
love you Apprentice means son uh let's
let's be honest and so the armorer says
you know what that's actually the one
loophole to this rule let's go ahead and
get this guy going he's now your
Apprentice Roku touches the Living
Waters awakens the mythosaur and then
the armorer says thank you for helping
us all reunite and come together as one
tribe now get out now you go now you
have to go because we're going to
relight this great Forge and we're gonna
smoke a little weed we don't have grogu
around what that's what I think happened
he's 50. he's older than most of them so
Mando heads out into the sky with grogu
and he makes a freelance deal with
Carson Diva basically saying like hey
season four is going to be a lot more of
those fun Western Adventures where I go
and do one thing at a time does that
work for you as The Narrative of season
four car sativa's like do I get to be at
the beginning of every episode giving
you those orders and earning a sweet
paycheck yes that works great I like how
he used the term independent contractor
because you know there's a lot of VFX
workers who are like hey that's my job
done
and I think we got our our core three uh
felony uh Rick uh fuyama and uh and uh
Deborah challenge yeah definitely saw
filoni back there yeah I think there's a
few others back there yeah I definitely
saw the hat and I feel like I'll I'm
gonna listen again closely I feel like
Dave filoni his words were not captioned
because it probably weren't a script I
think he was just saying random Star
Wars in the background and they just
picked it up and they mixed it so you
can still hear him say like placoon and
like a totally hear him say stuff
like that come on we could get it we can
get a video out of that keep minding it
like best Star all right now as a gift
to his old pal grief cargo Dan return uh
gets a ig-11 fully reactivated to become
the Marshal of Navarro he's back tyco's
doing the vo may he Reign forever Goku
is now DIN grogu and Dan who's still
denying you get a cozy little cottage
just outside of the city and grogu does
his favorite pastime which is torture
during frogs as the sun sets on another
season of the Mandalorian and we get a
circle wipe on the two of them which
just feels so final yes quick question
do you think that Cara Dune uh when she
heard that uh a marshall uh her old job
was now being replaced by a Droid she's
like this is what I've been saying all
the jobs are being automated she talked
to Instagram whatever the Instagram is
in the Star Wars universe and compared
it to the destruction of Alderaan she's
like yeah a robot replacing me makes me
feel as bad as all of the aldaranians
that were destroyed whose planet was
destroyed and if you can get through
that mixed metaphor and find some sort
of burn on uh on Gina Carano then you
are our Wikileaks Wikileaks you are
Wikileaks fan of the day I'm having an
allergy attack I can't really feel
anything in the front of my head I'm
trying my best guys we're not doing so
good but you know what the force is with
us remember Saturday mornings you better
otherwise you should get that checked
out the weekly holiday where you'd
celebrate by watching cartoons and
eating cereal well they're back thanks
to Magic spoon magic spoon is cereal
reinvented it's a high protein zero
sugar cereal that tastes awesome no
matter what you're eating or what
cartoons are on at the moment magic
spoons variety pack comes in four
delicious flavors cocoa fruity frosted
and peanut butter come on SpongeBob fans
each flavor has zero grams of sugar 13
to 14 grams of protein and four to five
net grams of carbs in each serving with
only 140 calories per serving they're
also keto friendly gluten-free grain
free and soy free personally I'm a
sucker for magic spoons fruity flavor
put that in your bowl and eat it
it's like a time machine for your mouth
this tastes like I have no homework to
do no chores to do and nothing to worry
about but whether to sit on the couch or
sprawl out on the family room floor
click the link below to get some magic
spoon cereal today you can build your
very own variety box and choose from the
best-selling cocoa fruity frosted peanut
butter cinnamon roll and so many more
and to celebrate magic spoon's birthday
in April they're offering a free box of
their fan favorite birthday cake with
any order use the special link in the
description to make sure that you get
the free box and it's added to your cart
this offer will only be valid for a
limited time so don't you wait okay
magic spoon is so confident in their
product it's packed with a 100 happiness
guarantee so if you don't like it for
any reason they'll refund your money no
questions asked and if you're in Canada
or the UK well jolly good mate no
worries magic spoon ships there too use
the special link magicspoon.com
Rockstar's b day to get a free box of
birthday cake with your order cake cake
cake cake cake cake cake cake cake cake
egg magical
now Eric let me ask you something is
this mother Fenton story complete or
what yeah let's talk about the next
steps for his name is now Den grogu for
that mythosar moment and doesn't it kind
of feel Tommy you mentioned this it
feels like it I think there will be a
Mandalorian season four but increasingly
in interviews poloney and Fabro have
indicated that the Mandalorian does not
have to refer to specifically uh uh din
jarin or I guess in this case even grogu
uh specifically in but I just don't
think that there's more story for Boca
time to tell either like she's kind of
reclaimed her Birthright of reclaiming
the plan of Mandalore one that has
vegetation growing on it so like unless
that gets threatened again for the you
know umpteenth time in Star Wars history
what more story is there for her to tell
it kind of feels like they want to get
back to what season one was they took
out uh or they they completed really all
the story lines that they uh you know
the mythology sizing storylines for
these characters just got back to this
episodic Vibe where they're gonna merge
the Mandalorian with what they had in
mind for Rangers of the new Republic if
he's going to be doing these Bounty
missions picking off like Imperial
Warlords and what their Ambitions are
throughout the outer rim
um meanwhile they're going to sift their
focus for the World building of the of
the first order and setting up
everything in the sequel Trilogy over to
Ahsoka right doesn't that seem to be the
case I mean it seems like Dave filoni
has even shifted his Focus to Ahsoka and
that might be why season three has felt
a little uneven to a lot of people yeah
I I think I think that makes a lot of
sense I feel like there is an
opportunity in the in these like New
Republic storylines to bring a lot of
Legends characters that people like into
live action we already saw Zeb was he's
not Legends but you know he was from
Rebels and then yeah you know I think
there's a real opportunity to kind of
show what some of these characters maybe
even you know getting Billy Lord to make
maybe play like a Leia and her attempts
to try and work her way up through the
government uh in the new Republic
something along those lines I don't know
I mean I'm just trying to think I don't
know if that necessarily fits into
Mandalorian but perhaps someone like
that sending him on missions or giving
Carson tiva uh communicates to help you
know impede all this Imperial growth
regrowth that is happening uh but yeah
it definitely feels like Ahsoka is
taking over the storyline of how the
first order was was was developed I felt
a little bit like the overall cloning
storyline turned it narrowed so maybe it
needed to do this is what we're gonna
talk about in the second question
Gideon's cloning plan now with that it's
like it really became just about him
cloning himself to make the perfect
Soldier whereas that we were kind of
teased in the episode prior that the
cloning plan was like those of us that
have watched all of the Star Wars things
were like this is how we're gonna find
out how somehow Palpatine returned right
like this is how it's gonna be and it
kind of swerved it in a way that it was
like no this is just Gideon being like I
want to clone myself right he was on a
side mission that felt uh I have to say
it felt a little unnecessary and and
narratively unimpactful like I I know in
these after shows especially in
seasonalities when we tend to be the
most critical but like Now's the Time to
do it I think we can appreciate the
journey sorry to inter I don't think
anyone's gonna question the fact that
you and I are fans of the of a this show
and B the the world that that Star Wars
builds but I think in order to like you
know they would question us if we were
like yeah everything worked for me and
there was no Mr X that I thought were
not paid off well so oh they're gonna
question us either way I'm sure right
now people on Twitter say well you know
new rock stars Eric Claus are mad that
because the armor wasn't revealed as a
spy or I expose was revealed despite
that why it's bad no no absolutely not
I'm really really relieved that the
armor wasn't revealed as a spy because
even though at the beginning of the
season I was like the armor feels sus in
certain ways no the way the character
was written over the course of the
series over the season if she was
revealed to be a con an accomplice yeah
Gideon that would have been awful yeah
and I think the same for ax wolves there
just wasn't enough built in there to
make that reveal exciting I just think
bringing MAF Gideon back just feels like
I don't think we got any more out of it
if anything it just kind of did away I
think they wanted to establish the
cloning plot as tied in with brindle hux
and maybe have thrawn be the tip of that
spear in Ahsoka and then but like why
even bring back Giancarlo Esposito at
all just kind of do like a crazier fan
fictiony version of what he did at the
end of season one in season two yeah
like why can't the kind I think maybe
they felt they needed a big bad for the
season yeah
um but that's not always the case the
big bad can just be internal divisions
it could be man versus nature it doesn't
have to be Man versus a man behind the
curtain I I think that's like I think
it's it would be more interesting just
to see what kind of conflicts uh din
Jordan could have with Boca time where
both of the characters are right and
we're rooting for both the characters
but they have these kind of fundamental
divisions which they started this series
already having we that was already there
from uh from season two episode four get
your ass you know like just kind of
build on the work you've already done uh
it said we went in this really weird
Journey that just like I don't know made
sense uh but if we're looking at next
steps I am kind of relieved just to get
back to the simple
episodic nature of it uh I think they
maybe felt that they bit off more that
they can chew and that the two uh
faceless non-human characters or at
least you know gingering as a human
character but he's covered in a mask the
whole time right in a helmet maybe they
felt that they could get more narrative
impact out of Shifting the focus of That
World building and that mythology over
to Ahsoka where we have a lot of
relatable characters right it's just a
fascinating experiment that they're
trying to work and interesting that they
really stuck I mean he put his helmet on
re re-baptized himself in the waters of
Mandalore purified himself and uh and we
never saw Pedro Pascal's face again
right this season no yeah
yeah this is I think this is the first
season I mean at the end of season one
and season two we saw his face that was
it
um yeah we're being kind of hard on it
right now I'll admit um but I I do think
that there's some kind of interesting
connection with grogu in the mythosar
yeah I think roku's future as a
character is to continue need to be the
Mandalorian of this series I think it's
season four wherever we see him again
there he is destined to connect with
that creature I think in some way there
is that moment uh between them so I
think just in the same way that the the
creature kind of blessed Boca time with
her Birthright to reclaim uh Mandalore
uh I think grogu had a similar moment I
agree with it I agree so the darksaber
it's been destroyed what now what what
what do we what do we do like what the
the great forges we lit do you think
they're gonna make some new weapon or
new like is it the Warrior's Way that
there has to be like one sword to rule
them all or one Spirit or rule them all
I I think it's a good move structurally
to take the darksaber off the table yeah
um ever since mothgating ignited a dark
saber in the Mandalorian season one
finale I was like okay this is a cursed
blade it's in the wrong hands and it's
always kind of in the wrong hands it
always just tears people apart so I'm
glad to see it as I said before I think
the way they did it was just a little
rushed in just a little unceremonious
but not even like intentionally on
ceremonies it'd be one thing if it was
just like the way Harry Potter just kind
of goes it just snaps the older one and
tosses it over a bridge right I kind of
like that yeah uh but here it was just
like in the midst of battle where it was
really about two other people and that
battle correct me if I'm wrong didn't
feel like it was over the dark saber no
maybe it was maybe I'm off getting
wanted to reclaim it at the end of the
last episode he did it just the way it
was shot wasn't framed on the darksaber
in particular it just seemed like this
show wanted to move on past it
kill Bo Catan and I think I feel like he
wanted to kill Ginger I mean like the
death of both of them and then he could
continue maybe getting some blood from
grogu to get make his little Force
Gideons
um I thought that was his quest although
he did once again he was like surrender
the dark saber to me and I'll give you a
Warrior's death what's he gonna be like
okay like well everybody
she took the offer one time like it was
like I'll spare everyone if I give you
if you give me the dark side version
he's like sounds good and then he was
like I'm just kidding I'm gonna kill
everyone it was a joke
honestly I think there was a symbolic
gesture in taking the darksaber off the
table and crushing it this way and
almost saying like Okay the Mandalorian
is what it was in that first season it
is not a story about any kind of Jedi
mythology or any kind of uh lightsaber
and that's what I'd like to really about
season one is it did feel kind of like
as a simple lone wolf in the Cub story
about this weird Orthodoxy of the
Mandalorian religion and their history
and their persecution yeah I liked that
a lot and I like just a simple
relationship between uh grogu in between
a DIN jarin and I think by breaking a
lightsaber here in the same week pretty
much that we're seeing new lightsabers
ignited new interesting colors of
lightsabers ignited and Ahsoka I think
lucasfilm is saying okay if you want
lightsaber action gives me plenty of it
in Ahsoka so tune into that and and you
know I we know throughout Three Seasons
or well really two seasons we never saw
Dan get any kind of handle on the on the
dark
he couldn't barely even pick it up or it
was like he did he the momentum was too
much for him he was very clumsy with it
Boca tan obviously much smoother with it
but like still I think I think you're
right I think it was like ultimately the
these type of weapons laser swords as
they were they they belong over on
Ahsoka a good old Blaster and Crocodile
Dundee knife to the chest plate of uh
best guard uh Trooper is all we need in
Mandalorian you know yeah get him to the
back to tank sew him up Stitch him up
bring them back I don't think it's any
coincidence that the darksaber gets
destroyed in the same episode we learned
that vegetation has grown on the plan of
Mandalore and that specifically when
Groton looks through the water at the
mythosar They Were Somehow able to bring
in new light into this previously
completely dark chamber which as a
viewer I think we're both grateful for I
think this we could actually see what's
going on here very much but secondly I
think there's like a symbolism of life
and light finding their way to their
Wellspring yeah and that it allowed us
to appear clearly through this water
which didn't look as murky or cloudy or
whatever sediment was cloudy in
everyone's Vision down there now it's
just like a clear shot that almost feels
less uh imposing or fearful but it's
something like we're waiting for our
gentle giant Kaiju to awaken and
Champion us uh so it feels like a step
in the right direction morally and
um in like in terms of these characters
Souls finding Redemption I hope he
sounds like Snuffaluffagus from Sesame
Street I hope I hope John fabrow Works
in a reference to Mr Narwhal from Elf
yeah
hope you find your real dad
I'm the crying uh one of those little
penguins
bye buddy uh so I do have to bring up
something before we're gonna talk about
loose ends I have to pick up I what I'm
gonna call my line of the year of
dialogue John Favreau takes a lot of
for or
or drunk for his right he wrote one of
the most video game lines of all time in
that Navarro scene where grief cargo was
like I've given you the deed to a
cottage just outside the city limits
where you can return to in between
missions and at that point I wanted like
a triangle a PlayStation triangle to
appear up on the screen and be like
press here to see the map of your
cottage I was like the line you can turn
here between missions was that Carl
Weathers being like I gotta be a part of
season four and the only way I can
guarantee that is if din John comes to
his little cottage in my hometown I'm
like did he improvise that or did fafro
scripted either way brilliant
injected straight into my veins listen
it's not all Shakespeare folks sometimes
you just gotta tell the people what's
gonna happen uh I completely agree Tommy
I think there's a lot of lines in there
that just feel like placeholder and
they're like there's no time we have to
shoot this and the people who watch this
there will only be a couple of grapey
nerds yeah awesome on YouTube and on
Reddit and on Twitter who complain
otherwise people will be happy and by
the way I'm not complaining it made me
laugh out loud it was maybe not the
right reaction but I will take it uh I
don't have any problem with it I just
love I love a good old-fashioned hey
this is what you can expect next year
they're gonna come back to this Cottage
uh over the cottage gets blown up with
din's new wife inside and he's got to go
on a Revenge all right Loose Ends Eric
who the hell were the spies
um okay I think spy's looking back was
not really meant to say that there is
definitely another spy I just think uh
look I think writer's rooms will often
name these episodes at the very end
it'll just be the show we're showing her
just being like oh this one internally
writers and group people refer to
episodes as the episode number so they
they would refer to it as 307 sure or
308 or something like that
um but I think the spies just referred
to the conspirators yes of the Shadow
Council sure yeah is it right to call
people like that spies I don't think you
would call them off Gideon a spy because
he is who he is he's walking around
proudly he's a public war criminal
um but yeah I think that's just what
that was meant to be I don't think
there's any honestly anything more to
that what do you think about a lion king
or I mean are we gonna see her when we
next see her show up yeah or is her
character just gone and into the pages
of a of an Intrepid comic book writer or
something yeah I think she's just
someone who's uh like you know an
operative who's going to be active on
Coruscant serving the agenda of the
Shadow Council one way or another but
she is kind of like left she's like you
know KGB a Sleeper Cell people who lose
their contact when the yeah when the
Soviet Union collapses so they're just
kind of like left to their own devices
so we hire them and make them do uh
things for our government and well there
was that one line where moth Gideon said
that Dr pershing's cloning research
research was lost for now yes and I
think that might have just been two
words to suggest that Elia Kane is still
active and still has like a mission to
do it could still be useful to brindle
hooks into the first order all right
here's the question for me you know I'm
an armor freak why did they introduce
Grover's armor chest plate and then not
do anything more with it yeah I was
expecting there's gonna be a moment
where we forgot that he was wearing that
he gets shot right in the chest or that
some uh
and then we freak out and then we
remember oh he's got that chest plate
yeah I think that was just a little
moment for grogu to have the mud horn
yeah and that's it any word under his
clothes the rest of yeah I I don't know
yeah although could you imagine I mean
didn't groco get stabbed I'm a little
upset grogu gets stabbed I'm devastated
okay there's a big difference now that
he's an apprentice I'm kind of like hey
you know what he should have known
better but when he was just a foundling
I felt bad for him he needed to be
protected all right now we got this
great tease of the mythosaur early on in
the season and now all we kind of got
was its Last Action was opening its eye
we don't know if it's a if it's ever
gonna do anything or get ridden by
anyone we hope it will we assume grogu
touching the water and it reacting was
kind of like an awoke him in or at least
maybe maybe grogu has a history of
connecting with animals obviously
perhaps the the mythosaur was like all
right you'll ride me someday but you
know go out and uh capture some more
space pirates first and uh and then and
then and then and then come back to me
you got to be at least 130 to ride the
mythosaur yeah I I think maybe it uh
they felt it was just too soon to bring
in the mid to start I thought that would
have been just as fun of a like way to
destroy buff Gideon as having his own
light Cruiser crash into him I like to
think of the Mythic star now it's kind
of like a spiritual force that only
presents itself to mandalorians who need
to see it in that moment this way he
kind of stays like a disembodied
abstract concept that represents the
spiritual health of the planet Mandalore
as for some as opposed to something
practical that you know everyone has to
either fear or figure out how to tame or
whatever it is that's maybe for a future
season but for now it's just kind of
like almost like an otherworldly Godly
presence to certain specific characters
I think that's really cool Eric I think
that makes it makes it feel important
right like who gets to engage with the
mythosaur only the VIPs only the vims
the very important mandalorians uh all
right and finally
you never got anything wrong they're
just saving them for Ahsoka right that's
it absolutely we'll see thrawn in a in a
trailer for Ahsoka at some point this
summer and we'll definitely see him in
the Ahsoka Series yeah I think uh if we
were gonna see thrawn he would have
showed up in that shadow council meeting
that is that tends to be the way right
in Star Wars is rather than bring in big
cameos other than Luke Skywalker right
he was the big exception in sokotano
when she uh showed up uh but otherwise
characters tend to show up in hollow
projector screens you know in in video
calls and that's where they step in uh
to frame I mean that's how Maul was
introduced in Phantom minutes so it's
just like he walked in behind you know
Palpatine or Sidious so I think uh that
would have been the place where his like
thrawn's just on the bridge of a ship if
anything might we would have seen the
back of his head uh but I think this is
this is the thing that Star Wars does
now is they it with filoni in charge of
stuff on on uh Disney plus he kind of
wants you to just watch everything and
you can get bits and pieces from from
everywhere and that is your narrative
experience as opposed to people just
watching One show and I think that's why
this season has been such a litmus test
for a lot of Star Wars viewers if you
watched it and loved clone wars and
Rebels uh that kind of episodic Vibe
where they start to introduce major
chunks of like Star Wars Canon uh
Episode by episode and ways we weren't
expecting
um yeah I think viewers like that could
appreciate and really love this show and
that's why I was able to really love
parts of the Season just for their
action and how well it was directed and
just the fun of it uh but I think for
people who just want to watch just one
series at a time and understand the
themes and the character development uh
I can imagine why a lot of them feel a
little Whiplash yeah at the end of the
season sure sure I I yeah I totally
understand that and I I think it's like
you said it's baloney Preparing People
to have to watch everything with the
anticipation of the feature film right
like it's like we now know he's making
the film so you gotta watch everything
to get what the movie's gonna be
basically it's like rather than having
episode 10 and episode 11 in episode 12
it's like all these Disney Plus shows
and then the one movie to tie them all
together so I mean Eric let's do Wookie
leaks forever or wait we'll watch all of
it and and Tommy I think it's I I highly
recommend people go watch bad batch this
season because if you don't feel like
Mandalorian stuck The Landing the season
absolutely did and absolutely there's a
lot of uh a lot of fun uh World building
and and and and and and information
building into cloning in the Star Wars
World beyond the Cameron Owens so and I
hope season three of the bad batch is
even mightier than season two and God
bless the 40 000 of you that'll watch it
with me all right now let's find out a
positive note Eric it's been a pleasure
as always to do another season of a
Disney plus Star Wars show with you on
this wild ride we call Wookie leaks yeah
you too Tommy I I really love even if
some episodes don't hit with me it's
always just a delight to jump on with
you and it was so much fun to Bringing
Hector into this conversation uh this
season I wish I hadn't poisoned him
before the last episode so it could just
be us
well uh he'll be back soon because you
know that poisoning wasn't like a
permanent poisoning it was more of a
phantom thread poisoning out of love
right yes you share a kiss afterwards
wow crazy movie that was hey um but so
Wikileaks isn't going to be a weekly
thing uh for the next few weeks we're
gonna go back into the back to tank to
rest and recharge and when Ahsoka comes
back in August we're gonna be back and
we'll be talking about Ahsoka and I'm
super excited for that show it's gonna
be a blast so be sure to uh subscribe to
new Rockstar subscribe to Wookie leaks
review your podcast
um and you can follow me at eavos follow
Tommy at uh Tommy bechtol and be sure to
follow Hector and Hector is funny as
well and uh yeah you can also subscribe
to our new channel the Deep dive I have
a new video coming out on Friday a deep
dive into Guardians of the Galaxy uh
that's gonna be really great I think
you'll like it uh you can support our
growing Network by going to
nerdright.shop and getting one of our
Mando inspired shirts and uh we'll see
you next time everybody we have has
spoken